[Music]
all right welcome to games you should
know by heart because you're good at
memorizing games at home okay so we have
a game from the 1890s the 1900s the
1910s with no tax right Arjun okay first
game as one of the most famous moves
ever the move is so famous it has a
Wikipedia article I'm serious can't make
jokes like that and there's a lot of
apocryphal stories about this game right
Arjun yeah okay so this is Rufus versus
Marshall although in the big scheme of
things Marshall was sort of Lucas also
you know okay why is this like this
that's that I can see okay
so I never heard of his opponent
Levitsky but famous game so we started
by transposing to a French and Marshall
played the Marshall variation but nobody
plays it anymore so that we knows what
it is but if you play the Marshall in
the we Lopez everybody knows where that
is but if you and also in the Noteboom
variation there's also a Marshall gambit
but this movement the Marshall nobody
knows what is it anyone yes you know
right if that played often today nobody
plays that okay and the most common
moves are this should be Ford Indy after
Winter War whose game we looked at last
week Knight f6 and D takes ec5 nobody
plays anymore yeah so it's like a
reverse chigorin okay Knight f3 that
develops a piece and the players played
sort of okay because it was 1912 so what
you want them to do is it'll break
Bishop e2 is not the refutation of this
line so if you want to win by force
which I guess you don't this should be
five would make more sense probably
taking pawns earlier would be good too
all right but the opening isn't the
subject of this can get to memorize
which is why you have to memorize it
weird okay so this is sort of boring
still boring
okay now in principle I don't like them
of night 66 or if I was black night
takes III the same idea unless I can hit
the center how and so in this position
if I'm white I want to play e4 or c4 but
I can't because it's illegal so if I
can't hit the center I why would I why
am i trading that knife of that bishop
no I mean Arjun
yeah you know I mean all right so I
don't like that that gives black a nicer
Center than he had and it also opens up
that file right opening up the F files
good so yeah okay so Bishop g4 that's
what I call a low-rated players move
because it attacks a pawn so it was
recommended by very good but ken west
raises hand because it's ken west my
comer was a very good answer
that's better than my answer okay so
Bishop g4 tax upon and marshal defended
it yay okay
and this should once age three white
we're bonds okay now you know why you
haven't heard of the guy who was white
all right rook a e8 good move Queen d2
this should be floor yeah and when I was
white earlier in the game if I was white
I would have played Bishop b5 pretty
early and now marshals doing the same
thing
he's marshalling in his forces right
Arjun got good and the Knights pinned
terrible okay this is a except six so he
was afraid of 94 even though I could
take it so why was he afraid of it
hey four losses terrible so yeah visitor
six is terrible good up the two bishops
okay so black has all active pieces and
two pawns of the center blacks would go
through well blacksmith both of his
rooks be even by not moving his f8 rocky
had VF file because of what white did
and the bishop on h3 is ridiculous
Malvina can't believe it she won't even
come to class oh there she is
okay did women's class end terrible was
it taught by Anna was it taught in
Russian
that would have been better right what
little okay so a little bit of Russian
yeah Arjun likes Russian yeah I told him
to slow down anyway so after rook takes
f6 white played Rick V one
maybe he wants to play 94 out of them
queen c5 I guess he doesn't want to play
94 now now V for serious
so Queen d2 now it's less serious Bishop
c3 BC three Queen c3 so Marshall likes
to sacrifice but his opponent played so
bad he couldn't do it he was taking
things instead and again this maneuver
of putting the bishop on h3 that was an
unusual maneuver okay rook takes d5 BAM
and Marshall resigned now we'll look at
the next game wait that's not what
happened okay notice the pawn is pinned
so he played Knight d4 now all the
pieces are hanging are you confused
Arjun yeah me too
okay now white played one of the longest
moves on the board well not really so
White's queen is attacked because I said
so and white rook is almost attacked so
white played Queen e8 threatening the
rook on e8 confusing the audience and me
okay rook ef8 now we saved our rook we
doubled up and we're threatening pawn
takes rook I understand all of that
rookie five saving the rook I understand
that rook aged six so white played a
move here I would never well I get iPod
design here because it's embarrassed for
playing so bad so blacks pieces are all
gray and the problem with rookie five is
it's lined up with the Queen and this
rook this lined up here and this is
lined up here so something Bad's going
to happen
everything is lined up somehow for black
to win so it's not good
okay Queen g5 which helps black play
Knight f3 check winning the Queen but
the problem is
if the queen goes anywhere else your
rook on e5 is a defended so then
probably Knight f3 check would win look
take stage three would win right Dennis
yeah so Queen g5 and black played the
obvious move ken west that's relatively
obvious but more obvious you the first
who's a chemist what about it and Ken
West approves of this variation takes
Knight f3 check and actually there was a
game played today downstairs between
Isaac and Kyle and Kyle play Knight f6
check was the same fork forking three of
Isaac's Queen rook and King I guess I
assumed Kyle won let me know might not
have but I pretty sure he did okay so
white plays the trickiest move ever
which will have an even trickier move
which is good for our class right Arjun
yeah so instead of losing immediately or
giving a piece away in resigning he did
a counter-attack he got one of his
pieces away from that fork
he played rook c5 if I remember
correctly hey I do okay and now about
half of you in a normal class would know
the answer to this in this class I'm
assuming there's like three of you who
know maybe two now if you haven't seen
it before I'll give you a hint you ready
for the hint is a really good hint it's
the last move you would make think of
the last move you would make and that's
correct that's the right answer
so think of it you all have a last move
you would make you'd never make this
move or for Ken West I don't know you
know I got I defer to Ken West you have
you seen it so what's the answer
now you that's like a normal move I want
the craziest move you've ever seen ever
now that's the right answer
the craziest move ever well who said
that you sure yeah he's like I know a
bad move when I see it he's really
confident too he's like it's Queens III
I've played a lot of chess piece one
yeah and you have seen this before
yeah oh now you see who's seen this
before
Claudio that's it you're all the worse
you've seen it
who showed you what oh you still forgot
yeah so this is called if you go to the
Internet's the gold coin game or as John
Schrank said the golden coin game anyway
so the apocryphal story which is your
favorite origin is that what the game
when he played that move the spectators
through gold coins on the board to show
their appreciation yeah I'm sure that's
what happened
also that happened and Preston his
dreams every night he woke up anyway
then the other story which I believe is
also fake is that people bet on the game
when they were paying I don't believe
that either who's betting on the guy
with Wyatt never heard of him so I think
that just made up that's my version of
the story is that nothing happened but
okay the paying up one is possible and
then whoever bet on white what but I'm
the guide nobody's heard of him the guy
who was u.s. champion for four years you
bet against them that's what you get all
right so some of you are confused but
you were confused when you walk in so HG
Nighy to mate is good for black right
Ken okay FG is the similar except you
get to last one more move okay and then
if you play Queen takes g3 then 92 check
or nothing like g3 HG is illegal and if
FG I play what takes for clay and then
92 wins and nine f1 wins and I'm a piece
up so okay I can do this and be a piece
up and with my rook anywhere and if you
do nothing you're like war if I don't
take the Queen BAM well then Queen h2
mates are going
right Arjun yeah so white resigned yeah
but you Queen g3 if you see that you
play that that that's why we show the
game so Marshall was no good but he
played that so now we looked at the we
think he's good then we have the
Marshall chess club where's that at
Arjun yeah have you been there
good well hold on well Arab and Costello
I said you've been there and you said
yeah then you say what city is it in
right it's in New York
yeah who's think funny here by the way
yesterday and these were adults I was
talking about Laurel and Hardy and
nobody heard of them
none of them yeah there was is like who
and what and then and not only that not
only that here's the worst part one of
the guys saw Blazing Saddles didn't get
the law and Hardy joke now this audience
is terrible
okay next look at the game that was
played a long time ago and I was really
furious because in my last class I was I
don't know what I was teaching something
and I was like Steines Bambara laid then
and then people they were going to do I
was like who knows that game there was
like nope how do you not know with sense
fun part 11 what's wrong with all of you
I'm mad at all of you I know you know
everything yeah what ah I'm so VN now
tell me something about sinus that has
to do with me even all my lectures come
on what do i what I have in common with
him actually there's two answers that
are acceptable I just thought of the
second one okay the answer the answer I
wanted was that I went to his grave so I
yeah the other answer what I didn't
realize is the most famous tournament
ever Hastings 1895 which this game is
from and was won by you guys don't know
I told you last week don't bury right I
got married in Hastings but not that
tournament okay you know how I know this
game the science
him because Rex was there watching it he
was like here's this quarry sheet I was
like wow he gave me his notes okay
so this is one of those lines they'll
play anymore in this position they play
d3 but g4 is old school and then people
started playing Bishop d2 but this is
this is the oldest of the this is better
and I know one minute game with Julian
and he did a mistake I'm like so moose
from now and lost like four moves later
so the worst okay so in this position
the book move is Maggie for but vampire
Laban didn't play that lady five so you
know what's up right and then there was
a trade and there was a castle and black
play Bishop e6 and white play Bishop g5
and I shall just came to my chest camp
and they complained like I'm excusing me
both times of developing their bishops
and Knights can you show us the game
that's more like we play and I was like
no I can't I know there's no games the
database like that right okay
now black pretreated like a Frenchman
even though he was German was 1895 so
they played this should be seven
actually okay so now don't blame because
they trade all the pieces off now ready
okay every moves the capture okay now
technically if it was blacks trying to
move for example he would Castle and I
would prefer black but black did not
castle now in this particular room last
week there was a camp with Aviv and
Armin and and Greg and Armin was the
main instructor of he didn't instruct at
all and Greg maybe instructed wanted a
donut some cupcakes let us to define and
cookies true story
okay and Armin was telling the students
like when you castle and the other guy
doesn't castle you should attack their
King and they were like we have a break
we have cookies that was their answer to
that okay then he taught them the end
game and they would just sit there
crying in the corner because it was the
end game they're like I'm excuse me
we're children we don't do that okay so
white who was the world champion somehow
he insisted on keeping black king at the
center so you played Ricky one obviously
frankly
now if white could cheat and move again
he would play Ricky five Queenie - Ricky
1 and Alex I would say ok you can do
that in copyright there a trade market
whatever is funnier okay so black played
the obvious move which I'm against I'll
give you a hint I said I was against it
f6 now Ricky 5 is risky so he played
Queen e2
black played the obvious move yeah Queen
d6 is obvious also but maybe Queen b5
check is good if you play Queen d7 okay
now I blacks advantage is that white has
this isolated pawn and there's very few
pieces on the board there's all those
trades but again the King still on e8
ok now both sides made mistakes because
this was 1895 so give them a break okay
white played Rick a c1 the correctly
with Rick a d1 and now black made the
losing move so wipe ever have a threat
here so we should get out of that pin
which is done very simply by king s7 and
then if you play Queen c4 check which
looks like a fork
I'm very luckily defend everything the
good player is always lucky okay and
then okay Blackfoot says rooks of the
center and it's equal but black made the
losing move c6 now in this position
remember I told you rook a d1 was better
the reason is after king f7 now what is
white play it's part of Rick ad once
that's a hint
instead of Rick a c1 d5 yeah and that's
sort of annoying I'm getting some
pressure now if you play d5 I will just
take it after King f7 beaten flaking f7
played c6 and now why it's actually
winning it's funny because the one white
piece that's not really attacking is the
night because I can't move the knight
anywhere right and you know this looks
pretty good this looks pretty good
okay and this is the definition of a
clearance sacrifice canwest does it all
the time by mistake and the answer is
well that's nice so what did he explain
yeah we can't play nice things before
because it's illegal but we can play d5
and then play 94 yeah so c6 wasn't good
and of the three ways to capture one is
illegal one hangs of Eaton one and one
is the right move so this is the illegal
is the sound time yep so the computer
let me do it this hangs Mayton
recommended by grandmaster ken west and
then you played the other one the one he
played and Knight d4 has explained now
if it was white smooth now origin not
think about this okay
you have to think it was white smooth
what would been Feingold
recommend are you Arjun yet knife f5
yeah a knife f5 is crushing and black
didn't want way to do that so black
played king f7 finally the knight has
another good square e six now White's
threatening rook to c7 which is annoying
and I won't make my usual joke for
obvious reasons in black play tricks c8
which stops my move
and he wants to pretend like he canceled
pretending is fun okay alright queen g4
threatening Queen g7 with advantage
right also Knight g5 is not bad because
it's Czech and threatens Queen takes
Queen but okay this is more annoying so
you can't play 96 because this wins the
Queen it's checked and an attacks the
Queen also your window look terrible
okay so he played g6 and after the
obvious Knight g5 how did white out of
white
how did black save his king and his
queen you don't want to lose either one
doesn't have a good fighting spirit yeah
what like a yeah that's better than
resigning right all right now for the
most famous sequence of moves until
Marshall play Queen g3 marshalling in a
new era of sequences of moves which is
one mode so what's the most obvious
sacrifice everybody sees it what riki
seven right okay
you've seen this Arjun you have seen
this I don't believe you
yeah so I'm waiting like a waiting
that's time we'll be like oh yeah I've
seen this I'm waiting
if you have sealed be like oh that's
right I've seen this if you don't do it
then you're right when you're right
you're right okay that's what I'll get
Kit Kats anymore because I'm going to
say the wrong stuff
okay now black played the obvious move
claudio what king where king g7 okay e7
right now he didn't do that because that
would that wouldn't be funny at all
no then Claudio is like I thought you
don't know this game you said you did
this game so you don't know this game
you don't if you don't remember the next
one you've seen this game I don't even
believe you now now you're just lying in
my class I mean Queen e7 kingi sevens
complicated but I'll show you
Queeny sevens not complicated I I'm a
piece up and I trade Queens I mean
that's not complicated right a king e7
loses he didn't do that he because I
think let's see rookie wand my life yeah
and now while King f8 ridiculous I take
your queen and this losses to everything
but this is winning your queen and 95
check so king d6 is the interesting
there's actually a line of analysis
where they give the wrong variation
which is funny
so then check King c6 Rick c1 mate
so King c7 is better and now I think
this is the right move and then this and
then this and there's there's more than
one way to win but okay but surprisingly
Claudio didn't say that move win the
game and still hasn't said it and he
said every legal move you hey if I King
f8 of course yeah that's why this game
is famous because of the next sequence
of moves so King f8 the funny move
because it hangs blacks Queen the two
pieces also funny is White has four
pieces and they're all
hanging also funny okay but rook takes
rook mate is annoying and if you were my
kid you'd say it's not made and you'd be
right okay so the sequence of moves that
happens now is very famous
even though Claudia is like King f8 but
and claims you've seen the game terrible
okay
so yeah why does four pieces hanging and
made so he played rook f7 Chuck now
black has three legal moves confusing
ten West who doesn't see all three right
where you do yeah there we go
okay so King Egan is really bad because
of me okay and King G had happened and
Queen f7 is also not good because white
takes all the blacks pieces not good
okay so he played King g8 and again if
white takes the Queen black plays rook
c1 by the way you at home I can't
believe they most people don't know this
game I've never been so mad from this
game a hundred times and that was today
okay you don't own it home either so
don't look so smug
alright now the obvious move origin
based on ricky seven recap seven g seven
okay so obviously King g7 is risky
because you lose all your pieces would
check so that's probably not good and
Queen g7 losses for the same reason we
keep talking about white wins olive
blacks pieces King f8 losses because I
play Knight h7 check and if you take my
rook I take the Queen with track and if
you play King Yeates you're setting up
for the next game okay mate so black
played
argent King h8 so you notice how the
game went ricky seven King f8 rook has
seven King G a trick so therefore white
played the cage seven okay and black
resigned except it says black resigned
but black didn't resign black got up and
left and went home okay and then he got
smite Hikaru Nakamura good sportsmanship
award alright so he resigned
obviously Queen take struck again losses
for the same leaves we keep talking
about so the reasoning of design was
after King GA
we do it again except this time there's
no H pine so I can play this check which
I couldn't do when there's an H point
and so forth and black only has one
legal move every time this last the
longest not clean f8 ok with a mouse
slip I could lose this game ok and King
hears terrible
you guys agree because it's mate next
move so that's terrible and King here is
correct and then Queen check Knight
check and mate yeah and both players saw
that because you no longer turned ever
right Ken West would have seen it but he
was busy that day
yeah he was gay his version if I good
it's like where's my birds Devoran come
on yeah so after the sequence of moves
resigned ok
also there's a Wikipedia article about
this tournament with pictures of the
cross table of the tournament there like
a 26 24 player round-robin something
like that big round robin and won by
toes bare as we discussed now the story
of the game other than that's a great
game is before this game Vaughn Bardo
Laban hasn't lost a game and this was
round 10 so his first nine games
undefeated he really never heard of him
then after this game the next 12 14
rounds in win a game right so you don't
that means Arjun the truth hurts yeah so
the one game destroyed him forever then
they never heard of him but now you have
did he lost and you never heard of you
were like what's that game where are and
I was like calm down why you breakin the
whole place up right yeah okay so that's
Sciences best game if I say his worst
game as you all walk out because
Sciences where schemes are not good but
that game was good okay and science was
old-school in 1895 size was old yeah all
right
you should have though you forgot okay
now this game is one of the most famous
games ever it was a manual after beating
william napier napier died when he was
like five or something he didn't live
long maybe it was briar or both of them
I get them confused and Lasker said of
this game
Nathan played a brilliancy but I won
okay and I analyzed this scheme once
I've analyzed it here at the club that
you guys were asleep I analyzed this
game in California at a tournament with
a friend of mine we were sitting outside
and like the term ahead and started yet
we were to hotel and it was nice and
sunny and by the pool and we were just
like looking at chess and he had a book
and he's like looking at this game and
we looked at this game okay and this
game has a lot of like unusual move
sacrifices attack weird and I got to
attend game okay so it's laster date
year last year was the world champion
was he's a world champion during this
game yes he was tennis is played in
Cambridge Springs which is in what state
Arjun now Pennsylvania okay
and I think wilkes-barre is also in
Pennsylvania can they both be in
Pennsylvania and I'm probably confused
and now I give up on Cambridge Springs
it might be Massachusetts now I'm
YouTube they're going to be like it's in
Germany
what's wrong with almost positive yeah I
agree with you even though I'd never be
with them now I'm sure it's in
Pennsylvania not oh no I don't want
looks bad anyway whoever said
Massachusetts they were wrong even if
it's the right answer because that's the
top class okay all right so Laster is
white and they played Sicilian and they
got to some kind of Dragon okay very
strange move order but it's 1904 so give
him a break g4r are was Matt Larsen of
Aryans
so do you know what opening was invented
a bridge Springs Arjun all right so G
for rar rar came add castles g5 the
point all right 98 very suspicious I
guess with 9 h5 I just played this
should be 2 and take it and also he
played 9 h5 all those shirts that you
have from across the street wouldn't
exist
no the 95 shirts that he's like yeah
that's right ok so where are h4 her mad
97 f4 wow I guess I'm not white yeah
yeah
well that's why it's a famous game be 5
speaking of risky right now II too
d5 was this MVL black this game maybe
get that yeah so blacks opening the
center because White's King is that he
won recommended by Armand the guy who
was here last week of the white one this
game button ke D Knight d4 so blacks not
kidding black he'll do anything now at
the game that was at the camp they
actually followed this these two
beginners they sell played all these
moves I was like what and then the game
went bishop f29 TF three million and
then they agreed to a draw because
neither player knew was made yeah
recommended by Isaac okay now that
didn't really happen but it's a good
story
okay so nice HD for Knight takes d5
confusing the audience so whites up a
piece but all these pieces are hanging
so can Westwood know what to do because
all these pieces are hanging he's the
expert there you go you know yeah that's
your usual solution right yeah hopefully
you couldn't hear him good it was funny
alright Knight f5 you were right yeah
nice nice f5 say bases nine hanging but
now the knight on d5 is hanging
confusing the audience so if you take
the knight I could play queen JD five or
nine takes d5 let's take the other night
yeah and the knight on f5 defends the
Bishop on e3 now I wasn't born yet so it
was just Knight f5 it wasn't ninety five
five right Bryan Adams favorite move
right you're Canadian so you get it yeah
you're not Canadian but you're old so he
got a little mixture ball
okay so 9f5 now if I was playing this
game I'd resign with both colors that
nobody would ever look at it I'd be like
well the game ended quickly I'm very
confused here because all the pieces are
hanging however White's up a piece so
he's got something going for him yeah
yeah he's like wow when did that happen
I'll show you when half an argent missed
it Knight takes d4 winning a piece and
they didn't take back you play here
expecting Knight f5 no nobody expected
that okay Knight takes c3
the Queen's hanging on v1 so Queen g8
rip D 897 say what kind of move is that
there you go Lucian's it yeah King h8
wow you were to play King f8 you POC
sirs okay now to apply King I say
without thinking then after like this
ship c5 later I'd resigned but later h5
not taking the 9th
because HG is annoying know what I mean
now hg is annoying rook e8 Bishop c5
defending the knight gh Bishop c4 not
taking the knight take spending the
night takes attacking the rook 94
attacking all of like pieces takes
[ __ ] eggs b2 now Arjun will tell me
the material situation and I'll wait now
make sure you're right these laughing is
like I know what's that oh you were so
close but you weren't close
Arjun did you count the rooks count them
again is it two pawns I don't know if
the funds are is he right yeah so blacks
down a rook for two pawns
you're like a rook with the rook oh yeah
but this is a tact this is a tact this
is a tax and if the bishop moves this is
attacked and this is a passed pawn it
doesn't matter this is a passed pawn
okay so very confusing and why can still
castle either way and does no okay so
rugby one obvious move Bishop c3 checks
pretty obvious King moved Bishop g4 okay
now both bishops are attacked and this
King doesn't look very good
this rook doesn't look very good blacks
pieces look really good right but blacks
down a rook so the truth hurts yeah so
complicated this is like all the Blitz
schemes I watch outside right and then
most moves are illegal later yeah okay
- takes h5 saving the bishop and winning
upon but not saving the other Bishop
Bishop takes rook takes now the obvious
move what's that louder or clearer
Knight takes once on c5 so that you
don't want to win this rook and you
don't want to win this rook how I said
the move was obvious I was kidding
that's not too obvious is it exciting
right okay so he took the rook on h5
because taking it looks better right
yeah okay now what's the material Arjun
easier question right but blacks King is
bad and white has an active rook on the
D file and white pieces are good okay
now what's the material Arjun equal okay
who's rook is better right who's King is
better yeah
so White's better yeah so white gave his
rook back and got a good position okay a
five very suspicious rook b3 is the
bishop trapped no g7 Rick h3 you knew
when that Rick was on b7 it was going
the h3 that's what you were thinking
right Ken
okay now no okay so the Knights hanging
so Knight g3 King f3 threatening the F
pawn Rick a6 takes the F pawn now
White's a pawn up check King f5 now
white Kings a lot better than blacks
King now Knight c3 a3 saving the pawn
which is funny 94 these is this sort of
a boring part of the game now in a very
suspicious whatever black designed
blacks down upon his rook is worse as
night as worse his King his horse and
his rook is virtually trapped terrible
and because of Bishop III White's
threatening g6 and I can assure you g6
is very annoying I ain't kiddin if Y
played g6 here you might get mated son
threatening ribcage 7mate if you play h6
now you see why whites bishops on e3
this is a stage six and that's also
going to be made this rook Knight and
pawn are going to meet you in Queen yeah
and somehow black has all his pieces on
the a file so black stacked apiece and
got a big attack and then factor rook
and got a bigger attack then white gave
all his material back it was better yeah
so that's a really famous game because
nobody knew what was going on okay
including me
right I've looked at that game with
notes and then after the notes were like
what we can understand the notes either
and that was a famous tournament because
the Cambridge Springs was played so
often but this game was great and you
never heard of Napier aren't you ashamed
look how good he played yeah and it was
funny because it was actually a
brilliancy from blacks point of view
black sacrificed everything every move
in the opening he played d5 94/95 sacked
his rook kept sacking White's King was
very suspicious but Laster gave all the
material back and got a good position
and a lot of you guys don't do that when
you're getting mated and you're DUP a
rook you'll help you up a ruck and you
get made it but if you give back to the
material sometimes you can turn it
around because you can get rid of the
attack so yeah last year said it was
Napier's brilliancy but I won and the
truth hurts yeah that's why last was
world champion a million years you guys
never heard the other guy all right
those were games you should memorize my
favorite of course was yeah see you're
the highest Regent you're always right
yeah I like this find this game I don't
like a lot of science games I must admit
but I like that one I liked his opponent
walked away that I liked that's what
that's part of the game instead of
resigning a good game he got mad he got
mad but like he wasn't like completely
winning and blundered and got man using
dad like I hate losing or okay I've
never had never seen a German net before
alright so don't forget that this video
Trump's other videos and I'll pass stop
it and I'll see you guys Sunday for the
kids class and we'll make fun of the one
o'clock kids again alright bye everyone
you
[Music]